yeah it is right yeah now here you are pretending that oh i don't know why the gas is not running
yeah i actually don't know why the gas is running did you actually pay the bills this week this
month did you just not pay the bay and no but yeah you're blaming it on me automatically right
maybe no you fucking keep on maybe the gas why are you why are you yelling at me like oh i's like
oh the water isn't working and you immediately start running like you know throwing shit it's
same exact shit as yesterday like i didn't do anything i didn't even come to you in an
aggressive tone and you immediately start yelling
ricky ricky suppose that it that i should know i should know i should know ricky you should know
that something happened with the gas i don't fucking know did you pay the gas bill or not
maybe that's that one well then that's definitely not my fault so why are you yeah you were you're
like oh you should fucking know you're stupid you're a piece of shit because you told me before ricky
and you that's something whenever life reacts with you right i asked because you are now you are the
you are more you because it's impossible for me as a human being not react it's impossible for me
what are you talking about you tell me you're an adult you're a piece of shit and i and you i'm supposed to
no you're yeah no because that's how you react look at your body language look how look at you're
raising your voice yes ricky what but you started i didn't even i i came to you i just said oh the hot
water is not working and you exploded exploded why ricky because this guy ricky that the yesterday
right that's that's all it's huge you cannot imagine the the food they gave this present this woman
came from yamanashi to say thank you to you right and it was my fault i mean yeah you were like freaking
out it was my fault because i didn't i didn't wait for you and we went together but i explained no it's
because you you reacted you were you freaked out for every reason but i freaked out because this is this is
nothing to do with the hot water what are you talking about no it has to do with the no it doesn't
it has to you you don't don't don't connect ricky what do you mean don't connect you don't not connect
you don't not connect because you asked me you asked me hey why are you mad and i try not to be mad
and you are you're you're definitely not trying to be mad you're not not trying to be bad you don't
give a fuck how am i going to be no mad ricky because maybe you have a little bit of maybe you have a
little bit of self-awareness i don't know ricky how come that i do you expect me like this whole trip
was just a mistake like really i mean it's ricky you can think about this and whatever and by the way
you have done whatever you want nobody's going to stop you good good and nobody's going to nobody's
going to change you okay well i'm not coming tonight then okay that's fine like yesterday yep exactly like
yesterday oh well you know maybe maybe you should have been you know so reactive and so angry all the
time then how about that no it's really it's unavoidable nobody can be be you you know you cannot
expect that life is not bringing consequences you can like well yeah well then you know you should listen
listen to your own you should listen to exactly what you just said
you're constantly angry you know you yell and then maybe maybe this is the consequence how about
that i'm not gonna go why should i go before you just to save face for you no it's no space for me
really because because you don't call your grandma ricky ricky by the way i never go you you may think that
i go to uh to see your father your grandpa how many times in my life have seen exactly and then the one
time exactly and then the one time that you go you go because you wanted to ask for that fucking
introduction for for work businesses which is totally fine yeah yeah right so you were using me just as
like a way as an excuse to to meet him and talk to him which is totally fine i don't give a
what are you talking about that's literally the exact that's the opposite thing okay well then i'm not
going to go tonight and and then i'll be the one ruining the relationship i'm the one that's burning
the bridge i don't know why you have to be so upset about it has nothing to do with you so you can you
you can go by yourself i don't care because you don't expect that that affects me right well i don't
care i don't care i don't care okay you don't care yeah you know there's nothing with the gas
because last night was fine right i don't know the night was fine and this morning you come here
and asking me hey what is going with the gas yeah do you pay the it's my fault yeah even i didn't
even say that you you just exploded because you were mad about something that happened yesterday
and i thought we're leaving at 11 not 7 30. because i cannot reach what happened yesterday
okay 11 is the moment that we meet with this guy and and and his wife but we have to depart from
here at least two hours right well i don't actually already told you i don't want to go okay call your
mom and ask him because he he will understand that but i am not going to to say that to him hey call
okay just be silent then just say nothing i don't care i don't care what you do you know
and by the way i personally for your father i don't have any consideration i am getting
consideration for tomoko sama she is she's a person she's the only person actual mom huh
you don't you know what are we going to do tonight uh it doesn't matter okay
okay that's that's the reason you don't pay attention you don't you don't it doesn't matter
for you it yeah i'm just i'm just focused on getting like going home because you obviously are
oh like i can't you look that's your decision yes and that's your decision okay well then there's
nothing to talk about leave me alone ricky
i don't because i don't know why that's why i asked you maybe it's going to turn on one a.m oh
no two or three when i went to bed it was hot water oh so it must be my fault i don't know i don't
know if it's your fault no that's that's literally what you said but that why am i even talking to
you there's nothing to talk about i already told you what i'm going to do i already told you my plan
you already told me what you think of me and whatever so i there's nothing to say anymore i don't
have anything to say to you anymore so if unless unless there's any new information that you want
to tell me leave me leave me alone there's no reason why why you already know that i was sleeping
if you don't have anything else to tell me leave me alone yeah
wow